مرحباً اسمي Olivia Lanes وأنا باحثة ومعلمة في IBM Quantum. هذا الفيديو يُطلق سلسلة
جديدة تماماً على قناة Qiskit على YouTube ومنصتنا التعليمية بعنوان الحوسبة الكمومية في
التطبيق العملي. باختصار في هذه السلسلة سأريكم كيفية استخدام حاسوب كمومي موجود الآن بأقصى
إمكاناته. هناك مليارات الفيديوهات على الإنترنت عن الحواسيب الكمومية وإمكاناتها المستقبلية أو عن المفاهيم النظرية
وراء الحوسبة الكمومية وهي أيضاً مهمة بنفس القدر. شاهدوا فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمومية
الذي يقدمه John Watrous مثلاً. لكن في هذه الدورة سنفترض أن المتعلم يعرف ربما أكثر قليلاً
مما اعتدنا عليه في الماضي وسنذهب بعيداً جداً من الناحية التقنية. وذلك لأنه خلال العام الماضي وفي وقت
هذا التسجيل نحن في 2024 رأينا تحولاً أو انتقالاً طورياً إن شئتم إلى حقبة جديدة من
الحوسبة. الحواسيب الكمومية أخيراً تقترب من النقطة التي يمكن أن تكون فيها مفيدة. رغم أن التجريب مع
دوائر صغيرة الحجم وحواسيب كمومية كان ضرورياً لتثقيف مجتمعنا حول كيفية استخدام هذه الآلات لم يكن أحد يشغل تجارب
لا يمكن إجراؤها أيضاً على الحواسيب الكلاسيكية العادية القديمة. لكن اعتباراً من اليوم دخلنا حقبة
الفائدة الكمومية. وما هي الفائدة قد تسألون؟ هي مختلفة عن التفوق الكمومي الذي يمكن فهمه عند
النقطة التي تتفوق فيها الحواسيب الكمومية على الحواسيب الكلاسيكية في مهمة ذات معنى. بدلاً من ذلك الفائدة تعني
أنها يمكن أن تبدأ بالتنافس مع بعضها البعض وهذه الخطوة الطبيعية التالية في التطور
التقني. IBM نشرت ورقة أظهرت لأول مرة العام الماضي أن حاسوباً كمومياً يمكن استخدامه
لمحاكاة نموذج فيزيائي ومنافسة تقنيات المحاكاة الكلاسيكية الأحدث. بل تفوق على
محاولات القوة الغاشمة وأعطى الباحثين مساراً جديداً يمكنهم استخدامه للبحث. فلماذا يحدث كل هذا
الآن؟ في الأشهر القليلة الماضية أتاحت IBM معالجات كمومية بأكثر من 100 qubit على نطاق واسع. إذا كنتم
مستخدمين بالفعل فربما لاحظتم أننا أزلنا الكثير من معالجاتنا الأصغر لإفساح المجال لهذه الشرائح الأكبر وشعرنا أنه كان مهماً
جداً فعل ذلك لأن بعض أعداد الـ qubit لا تزال يمكن محاكاتها كلاسيكياً بدون مشكلة لذا ليس هناك
ميزة حقيقية يمكن اكتسابها من استخدام هذه الشرائح. لكن عند 100 qubit لم يعد هذا هو الحال ولا يمكن
محاكاتها كلاسيكياً. من المهم أيضاً ملاحظة أن هناك أشياء تُسمى المحاكيات وهي
في الأساس برامج حاسوبية يمكنها تقليد بعض سلوك الأنظمة الكمومية بما في ذلك الضوضاء. لكن من فضلكم
لا تفوتوا حقيقة أنني قلت تقليد. المحاكيات ليست حواسيب كمومية ولا يمكنها إنتاج النتائج التي
تنتجها الحواسيب الكمومية بهذا الحجم. لكنها لا تزال جزءاً مهماً من سير عمل الاختبار لدينا. كان ذلك
جواباً مطولاً جداً للسؤال أعلى هذه الشريحة: ما هي الحوسبة الكمومية العملية؟ في هذه الدورة سأعلمكم عن حالات
الاستخدام المحتملة الواقعية للكم وأفضل الممارسات لتشغيل التجارب على هذه المعالجات
الأكبر حجماً اليوم. لمن هذه الدورة موجهة؟ لنبدأ بتحديد المستوى
في البداية. هذه الدورة لكل من يهدف لتطوير تطبيقات جديدة للحواسيب الكمومية ويريد
معرفة كيفية توسيع عملهم الحالي أو تعلم كيفية استخدام الكم في مسارات عملهم الحالية. ذكرت سابقاً
أن هذه الدورة ستكون عملية جداً ولن نناقش الجوانب النظرية بنفس القدر تقريباً.
نتوقع أن تأتوا بفهم أساسي لما هي الحوسبة الكمومية لكن إذا لم تصلوا إلى هناك بعد فلا مشكلة فقط شاهدوا
الحلقات الأولى من دورة John Watrous وستكونون مستعدين. نريد أيضاً التأكد من أن المشاهدين يعلمون
أن هذه ليست مجرد دورة للفيزيائيين أو حتى لعلماء الحاسوب. هذان الموضوعان احتكرا
الحوسبة الكمومية فعلاً خلال العقد الماضي أو نحو ذلك. نريد التأكد من أن الآخرين الذين يعملون مع البيانات الضخمة أو
المحاكاة مثل المهندسين والكيميائيين وعلماء المواد يعلمون أن هذه الدورة لهم أيضاً. باختصار هذه
الدورة موجهة لجمهور واسع ونأمل أن تنضموا إلينا لكاملها. عند إكمال هذه الدورة
ستتمكنون من فهم كيفية إنشاء وتشغيل مهمة بمقياس الفائدة العملية عبر Qiskit Runtime بما في ذلك سير العمل الكامل
وستتمكنون من فهم الأنواع الرئيسية لتخفيف الأخطاء وكذلك فهم مجالات التطبيق المحتملة على المدى القصير. ستتمكنون أيضاً من
تنفيذ كل هذه الخوارزميات في Qiskit وأخيراً نتوقع أن تتمكنوا من فهم الضوضاء وكيفية التعامل معها
لنبدأ إذاً. الحوسبة الكمومية تقنية جديدة مثيرة في مرحلة مبكرة من التطوير لكنها مجرد
فصل واحد في قصة الحوسبة التي تعود لآلاف السنين. أعتقد أنه من المهم فهم هذا
السياق لأنه يجعل ما نهدف للقيام به هنا أكثر بديهية وقابلية للتنبؤ وأقل
خيالاً علمياً. منذ العصور القديمة نحن كبشر احتجنا لإجراء حسابات أو
بعبارة أخرى معالجة المعلومات وفقاً لقواعد وقيود معينة لتمكين
التواصل والبناء والتجارة والعلم وجميع جوانب حياتنا الأخرى. لجأنا إلى العالم المادي
طلباً للمساعدة ومن خلال اكتشافات عبقرية بنينا أجهزة لمساعدتنا في الحساب. قديماً كانت الأجهزة
مصنوعة من الخشب والعظام والحبال المعقودة وكانت تخزن المعلومات وتسهل الحسابات بطريقة مختلفة كثيراً عما نفعل
اليوم. الأجهزة الميكانيكية المبنية من الروافع والتروس وآلات أخرى تطورت من الساعات الفلكية المبكرة إلى
الآلات الحاسبة إلى أجهزة حوسبة متطورة مثل المحللات التفاضلية التي حلت المعادلات باستخدام عجلات
وأقراص دوارة. حتى تقنية الكتابة لعبت دوراً مهماً في القصة بالسماح للناس بإجراء
حسابات لم يكونوا ليتمكنوا منها لولاها. عندما نفكر في الحواسيب اليوم نميل للتفكير في
الحواسيب الرقمية الإلكترونية لكن هذه فعلاً تقنية حديثة نسبياً. الحواسيب الرقمية الإلكترونية
بُنيت لأول مرة في الأربعينيات. أقدم أداة معروفة فعلاً للحساب هي المعداد السومري
الذي يعتقد الخبراء أنه اختُرع في بابل بين 2700 و 2300 قبل الميلاد. هذا زمن
بعيد جداً. لكننا فهمنا أكثر فأكثر عن العالم الطبيعي من Archimedes إلى Euclid إلى
Einstein وحاجتنا لمزيد من الموارد الحسابية انفجرت. اليوم لدينا حواسيب فائقة وهي
في الأساس حواسيب قوية جداً كثيرة مربوطة على التوازي. هي أحد أفضل الأدوات التي تملكها البشرية
لحل المشاكل الصعبة. لكن لا تزال هناك الكثير من المشاكل التي حتى هذه الحواسيب العملاقة لن تتمكن من
حلها أبداً. المزيد عن هذا لاحقاً. إذاً أثبتنا أن البشر استخدموا الفيزياء والطبيعة لمساعدتنا في الحساب
لآلاف السنين ولمساعدتنا في سعينا الذي لا ينتهي لحساب أشياء أكثر وأكبر. ربما
تعرفون بالفعل قانون Moore. هو ليس قانوناً بالفعل بقدر ما هو ملاحظة. جزء القانون هو مبالغة
بعض الشيء في رأيي. العدد الأقصى من الترانزستورات في دائرة متكاملة أي شريحة حاسوب
يتضاعف تقريباً كل سنتين. خلال العقود الخمسة الماضية أو نحو ذلك لم نلاحظ هذا فحسب بل استفدنا منه
بشكل كبير. بمزيد من الترانزستورات يمكننا إجراء حسابات أكثر وأسرع. هذا في الأساس ما هو مسؤول
عن جعل الحواسيب أقوى وأصغر بمرور الوقت. لكن هناك أخبار سيئة: قانون Moore يحتضر
الخبراء يختلفون حول متى سينتهي قانون Moore لكن البعض يقول إنه انتهى بالفعل. رغم أننا قد لا
نكون متأكدين بالضبط متى سنصل إلى حدودنا نعلم أنه حتمي في النهاية لأن بعض أجزاء الترانزستور
لا يمكن تصغيرها فيزيائياً أكثر. لا يمكنكم صنع ترانزستور أصغر من ذرة مثلاً. هذا
بالطبع غير فيزيائي تماماً ويبدو سخيفاً لكن هذه هي الحدود التي نعمل ضمنها فعلاً. فماذا
سنفعل؟ هل نستسلم ونقول هذا أفضل ما يمكن؟ لا البشر لم يفعلوا ذلك قط. لحسن الحظ ميكانيكا
الكم دخلت المحادثة. ميكانيكا الكم اُكتشفت في العشرينيات ومنذ ذلك الحين لم يعد العالم
كما كان أبداً. ويمكننا قضاء ساعات في الحديث عن الاكتشافات الثورية التي
تمت لكن ذلك ليس محور هذه الدورة. بدلاً من ذلك أريد أن أوضح أننا نعلم أن ميكانيكا
الكم والحوسبة متوافقان بالفعل مع بعضهما البعض. النتائج والفهم للطبيعة
الذي تعلمناه من ميكانيكا الكم جعل جزئياً حواسيبنا الحديثة ممكنة. بدون ميكانيكا
الكم لما فهمنا أو ربما لما تمكنا حتى من اختراع القرص الصلب ذي الحالة الصلبة
مثلاً. الحوسبة الكمومية هي ببساطة الخطوة الطبيعية التالية في هذا التطور
لكن الحوسبة لا توجد في فراغ. المعلومات تتطلب وسيطاً
حوسبة المعلومات تسخر العالم المادي وتؤثر فيه أيضاً. هذا يضع قيوداً على ما هو ممكن
فيزيائياً أصلاً. لكن فهم الطبيعة والقيود الفيزيائية هو في الحقيقة هدف الفيزياء
كتخصص. لذا بطريقة ما الفيزياء والحوسبة كانتا متشابكتين دائماً. Ralph Landauer عالم حاسوب
وموظف في IBM أدرك قبل عقود أن المعلومات فيزيائية. بعبارة أخرى المعلومات ليست كياناً
مجرداً بل توجد فقط من خلال التمثيل الفيزيائي. مبدأ Landauer يُنشئ رابطاً
بين المعلومات وقوانين الديناميكا الحرارية. لكن في الواقع هناك روابط كثيرة بين الفيزياء
والحوسبة. الفيزياء الكلاسيكية كانت كل ما تمكنا من استكشافه حتى وقت قريب لكن مع اكتشاف ميكانيكا
الكم نحن الآن على حافة القدرة على إنشاء طريقة جديدة تماماً للحوسبة. وهذا رائع لأن
الحواسيب الكلاسيكية يمكنها فقط تقريب ما يحدث فعلاً في الطبيعة وفي بعض الحالات ذلك التقريب محدود
جداً. وذلك لأنه من الصعب حقاً جعل الآلات التي تتبع قوانين الفيزياء الكلاسيكية
تُقرب قوانين فيزياء الكم. والطبيعة ليست كلاسيكية بل هي كمومية. تشبيه واحد قد يساعدكم
على الفهم هو نفق الرياح. ديناميكا الموائع صعبة الشهرة في المحاكاة والتنبؤ رياضياً
حتى شيء عادي كسيارة تسير في بعض الرياح. مصنعو السيارات وجدوا أنه كان
مكلفاً جداً وغير عملي محاولة محاكاة هذا التفاعل الفيزيائي عند تصميم السيارات. بدلاً من ذلك ما
انتهوا بفعله هو إنشاء نفق حرفي يُمرر الرياح من خلاله ويقودون سيارة إلى النفق
ويرون كيف تتصرف. هذا مشابه لما أعنيه عندما أقول إن الحواسيب الكلاسيكية تُقرب الطبيعة
بشكل سيء فقط وأحياناً يكون مكلفاً جداً حتى محاولة جعلها تفعل ذلك. بدلاً من محاكاة الرياح
الباحثون يعيدون خلقها. بالمثل الحواسيب الكمومية لا تحتاج لتقريب قوانين الطبيعة على المستوى
الجزيئي لأنها تتبع تلك القوانين بطبيعتها. لا تحتاج لمحاكاة أي شيء بل تُحاكيه فعلياً
ونفس الصعوبات تظهر عندما نحاكي البطاريات أو التفاعلات الكيميائية مما يقودنا إلى القسم
التالي: الحوسبة الكمومية لماذا هي مفيدة؟
لماذا نريد حتى التفكير في الجمع بين ميكانيكا الكم والحوسبة؟ هناك بالفعل الكثير من
المشاكل الصعبة جداً والمكلفة حسابياً جداً حتى لحواسيبنا الفائقة الأكثر تقدماً لحلها
ربما هذه مشاكل يركز عليها الباحثون فقط لكن تأثيراتها قد تمس جميع أنحاء
العالم. هذه المشاكل التي تتعثر فيها الحواسيب الكلاسيكية هي أشياء نعتمد عليها كمجتمع أكثر
فأكثر تقنياً ونهتم بها حقاً مثل كفاءة البطاريات والنمذجة المالية
والتحسين وحتى كيفية بناء طائرات أفضل. فلماذا نلجأ للحواسيب الكمومية؟ لدينا أسباب وجيهة جداً
للاعتقاد بأن هناك الكثير من الإمكانات هنا ويمكننا فتح أبواب لحوسبة جديدة بعيدة المنال حالياً حتى
لأقوى الحواسيب الفائقة. نظرياً بعض الخوارزميات الكمومية توفر مزايا على
أفضل الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية الممكنة لبعض التطبيقات. لتطبيقات أخرى هناك أدلة متزايدة على أنه حتى
مع بعض الضوضاء والعيوب يمكن استخدام الحواسيب الكمومية كأداة لمنافسة حلول القوة الغاشمة
الكلاسيكية. في الأساس هي أداة جديدة تماماً ونريد اكتشاف أشياء رائعة أكثر يمكننا فعلها بها. لكن يمكننا
أيضاً العودة لفكرة Feynman الأصلية لها وهي استخدامها لفهم الفيزياء والطبيعة بحد ذاتها
في النهاية أخبرتكم بالفعل أن الطبيعة كمومية وليست كلاسيكية. وهذا المجال غني ومذهل بشكل لا يصدق
ومتعدد التخصصات. يجمع بين الفيزياء وعلوم الحاسوب ومعالجة المعلومات وبالطبع مجالات التطبيق المحددة التي قد
نهتم بها. لكن على عكس الحواسيب الكلاسيكية ليس لدى الجميع حاسوب كمومي مخبأ في
جيبهم الخلفي. حتى وقت قريب جداً إذا أردتم التجريب بحاسوب كمومي كان عليكم بناؤه وصيانته
بأنفسكم عادةً في مختبر بدروم حزين في جامعة أو مرفق بحثي. وصدقوني أعرف ذلك. لم يعد
هذا هو الحال. في 2016 وضعت IBM أول معالج كمومي على السحابة. كان يحتوي على خمسة qubit فقط في ذلك الوقت
ومعدلات أخطاء عالية نسبياً لكن ذلك كان قبل 8 سنوات فقط وانظروا كم تقدمنا. فأين نقف اليوم؟
هناك الكثير من أوجه التشابه مع الأيام الأولى جداً للحاسوب الحديث. كما ذكرت هذا تحدٍ
صعب جداً وفقط خلال السنوات الثماني الأخيرة أصبحت الحواسيب الكمومية متاحة على نطاق واسع باستثناء
أولئك الذين يعملون في مختبر أو مرفق متطور. لكن في تلك السنوات الثماني أحرزنا تقدماً على كل
صعيد. المعالجات أكبر بمراتب من حيث عدد الـ qubit والبوابات تحسنت كثيراً وقدمنا طرقاً
لتقليل أو تخفيف الأخطاء الجوهرية في الأنظمة الكمومية حتى بينما نمضي قدماً لإنشاء حواسيب
كمومية متسامحة مع الأخطاء. الآن أنتم وأي شخص آخر يمكنكم استخدام أحد معالجات IBM Quantum العديدة
المستضافة على السحابة وتقريباً جميعها أحدث وأفضل الأنظمة بأكثر من 100
qubit. لكن ليس فقط حجم المعالجات هو المهم. هذا مقياس واحد فقط نهتم به
وهذا منطقي أليس كذلك؟ إذا كان لدينا qubit أكثر فهذا أفضل بوضوح شرط ألا تؤدي زيادة عدد الـ qubit
إلى تدهور الأداء. لكن هذا ليس الحال دائماً. نحتاج المزيد من qubit عالية الجودة لا تتداخل
مع بعضها البعض عبر التداخل الحواري عندما لا نريد ذلك. كيفية اتصال الـ qubit ببعضها أيضاً شيء مهم. في
الدوائر فائقة التوصيل يُشكل تحدياً معرفة كيفية ربط الـ qubit فيزيائياً بأفضل طريقة. مقياس آخر بالغ الأهمية
هو دقة بوابة الـ qubit الثنائية. البوابات التي تعمل على qubit مفرد ليست عرضة للأخطاء بنفس القدر. بوابات الـ qubit الثنائية هي
مجال القلق الأكبر بكثير وعادةً أحد المقاييس الأساسية التي ننظر إليها لرؤية كيف يتحسن الأداء
مع الوقت. بوابات الـ qubit الثنائية حاسم إتقانها لأنها مسؤولة عن إنشاء التشابك بين الـ qubit
وهو أحد الظواهر الفيزيائية التي تعطي الحواسيب الكمومية قوتها. أخيراً ننظر للسرعة والكفاءة
نحتاج للتأكد من أن الوقت المستغرق في تشغيل برنامج على الشريحة الكمومية يُنفذ بأسرع وأكفأ
ما يمكن. نشير إلى هذه المقاييس الثلاثة معاً بالحجم والجودة
والسرعة. جميعها حيوية لتحسين الأداء. الآن أريد أن أريكم بعض الرسوم البيانية السريعة لدعم ما قلته
عن كيف أن التقنية نفسها تتطور بسرعة كبيرة فعلاً. عدد الـ qubit نفسه هو الأسهل
للفهم أعتقد. وIBM نشرت خريطة طريق لأين نأمل أن نكون في السنوات القادمة من حيث عدد الـ qubit
وحجم المعالج. لعام 2024 عندما نصور هذا الفيديو نحن على المسار الصحيح مع معالجاتنا Heron و Condor. التالي
الجودة: هذا الرسم يُظهر متوسط معدل خطأ بوابة التشابك لمعالجات IBM Quantum عبر الزمن. تذكروا
أن هذا مقياس لوغاريتمي لذا بينما يبدو التقدم خطياً تقريباً فهو فعلاً أسرع بكثير من ذلك
وأخيراً لدينا السرعة. هذا الرسم يُظهر تقدم مقياس نسميه CLOPS وهو اختصار لعمليات طبقة الـ circuit
في الثانية. الأهم أن CLOPS يجمع كلاً من الوقت اللازم لتشغيل الدوائر والحوسبة الكلاسيكية الحقيقية
وشبه الحقيقية المطلوبة. في الأساس CLOPS هو مقياس لمدى سرعة معالجاتنا في تشغيل دوائر محددة
بالتسلسل ويعمل كمقياس لسرعة النظام الشاملة ويدمج الحوسبة الكمومية
والكلاسيكية. حالياً في وقت التسجيل IBM هي مزود السحابة الكمومية الوحيد الذي يوفر وصولاً لآلات
بأكثر من 100 qubit. كما ذكرت قبل شرائح قليلة عند 100 qubit أو حولها تبدأ المحاكاة الكلاسيكية
بالفشل الكامل لذا المهام الكبيرة التي تُشغل على هذه الآلات غالباً ليس لها مكافئ كلاسيكي. ليس
ممكناً. هناك بعض الفروق الدقيقة وبعض الحيل يمكنكم استخدامها لمحاكاة بعض أجزاء الـ circuit ثم أجزاء
أخرى بشكل منفصل لكن بشكل عام نعلم أنه حول هذا الرقم يمكن للحواسيب الكمومية البدء بفعل أشياء لا تستطيع الحواسيب الكلاسيكية فعلها. لذا
قررت IBM أن إتاحة الوصول لهذه الأجهزة الأكبر كان مهماً جداً للمجتمع الأوسع لأن أي شيء
يُنجز على أجهزة أصغر يمكن محاكاته كلاسيكياً وبالتالي لا يمكن أن يؤدي للتفوق الكمومي. أجهزة الـ 100 qubit
التي لدينا الآن لا تزال معيبة ومشوشة لذا نحتاج أن نكون أذكياء في كيفية تشغيل المهام
والدوائر عليها. مجرد كتابة الـ circuit بسذاجة والضغط على تشغيل على الأرجح لن يؤدي لأي شيء
مذهل. لكن مرة أخرى هناك نصائح وحيل يمكننا تطبيقها وأفضل ممارسات نتبعها لاستخلاص أداء
أكبر من هذه الأجهزة مما سيؤدي نأمل للتفوق الكمومي أسرع حتى بينما نستمر
في العمل على بناء آلاتنا المتسامحة مع الأخطاء أيضاً. هذا الرسم يُظهر تكلفة المحاكاة
أو مقدار الوقت اللازم لحل مشكلة على الحواسيب الكلاسيكية والحواسيب الكمومية المجهزة بتخفيف
الأخطاء وتصحيح الأخطاء. خط الحوسبة الكلاسيكية يتوسع أسياً مع نمو تعقيد الـ circuit
للدوائر البسيطة هنا في الأسفل لا يهم ذلك لكنه سيء بوضوح مع نمو التعقيد لأن هذا
يجعل تكلفة المحاكاة مرتفعة جداً بسرعة كبيرة. تخفيف الأخطاء يتوسع بشكل أفضل لذا عندما ينمو تعقيد
الـ circuit هنا نريد أن نكون. نحن حالياً هنا مع الطرق الكلاسيكية والكمومية متقاربة
مع بعضها لبعض التطبيقات. وتصحيح الأخطاء قد يكون الأفضل ويتوسع بشكل ممتاز
لكننا لم نصل إلى هناك بعد. في هذه الأثناء سنستمر بالتركيز على تخفيف الأخطاء والوصول لمنطقة
الفائدة الكمومية بأسرع وقت ممكن. وباستخدام عدة مخططات لتخفيف الأخطاء التي سنتعلمها
في هذه السلسلة نهدف لإيجاد مجالات تطبيق يمكنها الاستفادة من الفائدة الكمومية قريباً جداً وهذا
هو جوهر هذه الدورة فعلاً. لدينا هذه الآلات ونعتقد أنها قادرة على إجراء أبحاث مثيرة
حقاً فكيف نستخدمها؟ في هذا القسم الأخير من الحلقة لنناقش بإيجاز مجالات التطبيق
للحوسبة الكمومية العملية. هناك ثلاثة فروع رئيسية نعتقد أننا أكثر حماساً لاستكشافها وإيجاد مسارات للفائدة
الكمومية. الأول هو محاكاة الطبيعة وهذا يتعلق بمحاكاة التفاعلات الجزيئية أو الذرية وهو
مهم جداً لمجالات علوم المواد والكيمياء ولأسباب ناقشناها سابقاً نعتقد أن الحواسيب
الكمومية ستكون أفضل بكثير في هذا من نظيراتها الكلاسيكية. التالي هو البحث
والتحسين. الخوارزمية الرئيسية المهمة هنا تُسمى QAOA وهي خوارزمية هجينة كلاسيكية-كمومية. QAOA تستخدم
حاسوباً كلاسيكياً لتدريب وإيجاد المعاملات المثلى لـ circuit كمومية ونأمل أن نتمكن من فعل هذا بكفاءة
أكبر بكثير مما يستطيع أي حاسوب وحده. أخيراً لدينا الرياضيات ومعالجة البيانات ذات البنية. الحواسيب
الكمومية جيدة حقاً في إيجاد البنية في بيانات فوضوية حيث قد لا ترون أنتم أو حاسوب عادي
أي شيء. التعلم الآلي الكمومي واعد في هذا المجال ونهدف لاستخدامه لمهام مثل استخلاص
السمات والتعرف على الأنماط. إنه حقاً وقت مثير جداً لمن يعملون في مجال
الحوسبة الكمومية. لأول مرة في التاريخ يمكننا البدء في استكشاف منطقة من الحوسبة تقع وراء
الحوسبة الكلاسيكية. من يشاهدكم هذا قد يلعبون دوراً مشابهاً للرواد الأوائل
للحوسبة وهم لم يتصوروا ما سيأتي بعدهم. T.J. Watson من IBM قال بشكل مشهور إنه اعتقد أن هناك
سوقاً لحاسوبين أو ثلاثة فقط في العالم. ويا لقد كان مخطئاً. نحن
جميعاً أولئك الرواد الأوائل للحوسبة لكن في هذا المجال الجديد للحوسبة الكمومية. والكم غالباً ما
يُقارن بالحوسبة الكلاسيكية كشيء مختلف تماماً عنها وغالباً في منافسة معها. لكن
هدفي من هذا الدرس التمهيدي كان أن أقنعكم أنه من منظور شامل يمكننا رؤية الحوسبة
الكمومية ببساطة كالفصل التالي في قصة طويلة من الحوسبة. إنها طبيعتنا كبشر السعي وراء طرق جديدة
للحساب وتسخير قوة العالم الطبيعي ومعرفة ماذا نفعل بها. وقد فعلنا هذا
لقرون. الحوسبة الكمومية تقدم لنا أداة جديدة في هذا المسعى وعلينا اكتشاف كيف يمكننا الاستفادة
من القوة التي تقدمها لنا. في الدرس القادم من السلسلة سنتحدث أكثر عن أنظمة الـ 100 qubit
ونعطي نظرة عامة على Qiskit وهو SDK الخاص ببرمجياتنا الكمومية وكيفية التفاعل مع هذه الآلات بأفضل طريقة الآن. شكراً
على المشاهدة وسنراكم في المرة القادمة